tu as fait quoi comme opération toi
parce que là ça se voit pas du tout hein
du coup j'ai fait une allergie en tout
cas je peux te dire tu es très belle là
je n'ai pas de complexe voilà je n'avais
jamais fait de chirurgie et une fois mon
portrait dévoilé sur les réseaux sociaux
forcément on regarde un petit peu les
commentaires et dans les commentaires
voilà il y avait beaucoup de mauvais
commentaires disant que j'étais moche
que je ressemble à un homme que j'étais
pas belle on faisait des comparaisons
entre les différentes filles dans la
télé etc et en voyant tous ces
commentaires bon tu les as dans la tête
et ensuite je te vois donc à la télé je
te vois sur différentes prises de vues
que tu devais pas dans la vie de tous
les jours donc là tu te dis bon la
prochaine télé bon je me fais peut-être
je me refais un petit peu le nez et
ensuite je suis allée chez un docteur à
Paris donc de base c'était pour refaire
ma bouche et au final ce docteur il me
dit bon il y a tes cernes qu'elles sont
un peu creuses tu pourrais en faire un
petit peu là tu pourras un peu faire ici
dans le nez dans le menton de base
j'étais pas je suis pas allé forcément
pour ça